Luke here at the outdoor Boys YouTube
channel and I've rented a boat for the
next three days me and my son we're
shrimping fishing camping seeing
wildlife and rescuing Birds
[Music]
thank you
all right guys welcome to Woody Alaska
me and Nathan we rented this boat and
we're gonna go out and camp and fish for
the next three days
[Music]
well me and David got a long way to go
today we're going 75 miles out to sea my
destination is Montague Island which is
an island that borders the Gulf of
Alaska and Prince William sound
[Music]
this is my first time ever going this
far out to sea being the captain of my
old boat look at me sure I'm the captain
now
foreign
there's salmon jumping right out of the
water right there
look at that
Nathan you want to catch a salmon
I'm not sure why pink salmon jumped like
that but when you see salmon jumping
like that they aren't eating
so that's why you gotta snag them
well there we go we got two peak salmon
that we can use for halibut bait
there's actually five species of salmon
here in Alaska and pink salmon are some
of the least popular so you're allowed
to use them for bait most people don't
eat Peak salmon look at it they're just
jumping everywhere
well we jogged out five and a half hours
in relatively calm seas and we finally
got to our destination and
nasty swells here it's all wishy-washy
so I'm gonna turn around and heading
back behind this island
oh you see him oh he just jumped out of
the water
look at this
oh look at that right there
the other purposes yeah I think they
want to ride the bow wave should we give
them a bow wave
they're over here raising us
[Music]
I think we found a little island we
could hide out at for tonight
all right guys we find a nice little
island that we can shelter in for the
night and uh we're gonna go ahead and
drop some shrimp pots got some shrimp
pellets for bait
[Music]
oh
just kind of curious what the bottom was
like so I dropped a jig down and Bam
something hit it what kind of fish it is
will tell me a lot about what the
Bottom's like come on reel up here let
me see
yeah look at that are we going to keep
them it's a rock fish no we're gonna
send them back
I have no idea if that's a good spot but
I dropped my shrimp pot
[Music]
hey buddy you want to put the fishing
rods out while we make dinner yeah right
here
I'm gonna make up a chum bag I got a
chum bag here gonna drop a lead in it
then jump
gonna throw some salmon guts in there
drop this
all right rigged up a basic halibut hook
I'm gonna throw that over and let that
sit while we cook
well you can sit out here just jigging
while I make some dinner okay
all right we've been making one of
Nathan's favorite dishes spam mac and
cheese
oh there we go
[Music]
oh we got a fish
see what kind of fish is it
yeah you know what that is what that's a
card
well I mean
let's be spamming is that good you like
your spamming mac and cheese
sitting here eating in the school of
pink salmon just keeps jumping around us
they come into range I think I'll throw
a hook at them
he's feisty we love it
really bad
oh he popped up
see that I got dessert for you we got
some rice pudding bud I love rice Brown
oh I got something
[Music]
check this out
oh man he took it out full force there
another type of rockfish
luckily we're fishing so shallow we
could just return them
what you doing are you doing the Orange
Julius
the orange Justice
oh look at that look at that
oh come here come here you got this so
slow it's gonna happen oh it's a
flounder
yeah they got a flounder
sure is a pretty sunset
all right let's get our bed set up
all right there we go
foreign
Ty you having a good time yeah good it
is late we're gonna put the camera down
we've got a lot of fishing to do
tomorrow we'll see you then
oh that's pretty good morning Nathan
what's up do you sleep well yeah
I had to cut some Corners yeah we got
rolls and gravy yeah can we get it one
time
just take a chunk of biscuit just go
over here and dip it in the pot okay
these aren't biscuits are dinner rolls
but you know concessions got to be made
we're on a campout
do you want a breakfast cookie
check out these bad boys
ah look at that
oh
all right the first order of business we
gotta go pull that shrimp pot
oh we got some shrimp in there okay we
actually got some shrimp look at that
oh
there's a shrimp in here
all right there we go that's what we're
looking for a giant Alaskan shrimp oh
and that's a little baby Tanner crab
no we can't keep him and he's he's too
small anyways
there he goes there you want to hold
this guy
there we go
should be kissy all right let me see him
[Music]
there you go
let's go see about getting some halibut
shall we Nathan yeah
well I've never been here before so I'm
just gonna kind of randomly pick spots
to fish see what happens
[Music]
we have a smorgasbourg Abate salmon
Herring Pollock everything a fish could
want yeah all right I got a piece of
pollock and a piece of salmon
625 feet
takes almost three minutes for the lead
to drop all the way to the bottom but
there we are we're on the bottom
the wind's starting to pick up and it's
making this drift difficult so I think
we're gonna pick up and try a different
spot
I could see some classy water over there
we're gonna try that spot
here it's already fallen
oh yep you got one right off
oh he went down
I hope it's not
something odds
oh there we go that's a yellow eye
Rockfish can you keep that one that's a
nice yellow-eyed Rockfish right there
there we go
there you go
there we go that's non-splaged that's a
non-pelagic when you bring these fish up
from the depth their air bladder expands
and they have a hard time getting back
down so you use What's called the deep
water releaser this lead weight brings
them straight to the bottom
so down on the bottom you shake them off
just like Taylor Swift said
you want an apple I guess
Nathan didn't want me to cut it with my
bait knife
oh my gosh I guess that's understandable
there's a sea otter right there
rarely oh look at that killer whale
right there
I think those killer whales ate that sea
otter they did killer whales are coming
up behind him and I don't think he was
paying attention because he was looking
at us and all said he went down and the
killer whales were like all over him
[Music]
cupcakes
you can see how it's current we're
dealing with it is just ripping through
here
[Music]
all right Nate you ready for a hot dog
there you go Bud
I just got bite on that Rod a little
bite little bite
definitely something messing with it
just might not be that big
go
well now that we got lunch in us I think
it's time to try another spot
pulling the anchor up is really
physically demanding especially when
you've got 400 feet of line to pull up
so this motor is what helps you do that
but the motor is busted I don't know why
it's not starting
oh that anchor rope is covered in
jellyfish slime and they're stinging the
crap out of my hands
there's an oyster Farm on this island up
ahead and we're gonna see if we can't
buy some oysters you'll eat some oysters
with me yeah yeah awesome
oyster Farm you got a copy
I don't think anyone's home
that's where the oyster Farmers live the
only people who live on this entire
Island as far as I know
but I don't see his boat so he may not
be home right now
I got a little bit of a fishing spot
here but I don't know if the current's
too strong to fish it or not
let's give it a go
got about 768 feet of line out I'm using
three pound leads on each one of these
rods so it's a little bit like a six
pound anchor slowing our drift a little
bit
oh my bait's gone
oh
look I got a halibut
it's a little baby elephant
oh he's so cute
that is beautiful yellow wire
oh
oh oh
there we go got another fish oh
look at that that is a beautiful kelp
grilling
Kell Greenlee
there's a sea otter right there
Berg's got to keep her eyes peeled
Isn't that cool look at those glaciers
it's messed up hold on we're gonna
Rescue It
there we go
[Music]
yeah it's what's wrong with your neck
I see his head his head's backwards he
keeps doing this with his head
here
he's acting like he's cold
let's just
I don't know what's wrong with him but
something's wrong with his neck and I
think he's injured or something but
we'll give him a few minutes in here and
see how he does okay
Nathan did you name the verb yeah he's
the name Bob Bob the bird I'm glad to
see that you don't hate all seagulls
you're hating seagulls pretty bad last
trip
see
here let's see if he
everybody
you hungry
it kind of seemed like you're interested
but
yeah
well we tried to help Bob out we've got
him warmed up try to give him some fish
but there's something wrong with his
head he's sick or injured and but he's a
wild animal we can't take him home and
we don't have any vets we could take him
to so I think we just gotta put him back
in the water where he found him and hope
for the best
okay here you go Bob
bye Bob I hope for the best I don't know
what's gonna happen to Bob but he seemed
excited to get off our boat so
good luck to Bob
all right let's go get the shrimp locked
on her shrimp pots in the water let's
kill finest place to Camp I'm hungry
out
[Applause]
I'm putting nacho cheese on a bratwurst
yes I am is it an Abomination oh yes it
is
oh and we gotta be confessed I'm kind of
sad today I lost my Gerber knife I've
had this knife since I was 16 years old
my best series and I laid it down on the
rail of the boat and then it fell off
when a wave came
oh
that one hurts
why do we have this in here we need to
get some sleep so I'm gonna drop the
camera and I'm gonna see you guys in the
morning
what a beautiful Lagoon
this is a shipwreck right over there
oh hey Nathan
oh good lord hey buddy I got some hot
chocolate for you
[Music]
all right
come and check us out look at that
that's all that's left of the Salmon
Head
look at that that's a salmon skull
that's the tail and all the fish I put
in there
never have men work so hard for so few
shrimp
all right
yes I do I do
hi Corley
you know this is fun but it's actually
quite calm I think we might try to do
some deep drop fishing
thank you
you want to try fishing at 1200 feet
yeah
yeah all right bombs away
it's probably gonna take about four or
five minutes for it to get all the way
to the bottom
feed
still folly
there we go
we got two rods fishing at 1100 feet
oh the wind's picked up that's causing
us some problems
oh
we got a pretty good drift but the
wind's kicking up and we think we need
to reel it up
for a while
there's so much stretch in the line that
we could have a fish and not even know
about it
[Music]
well
nothing there
we're almost out of fuel our anchor
windlass is broken and the wind and the
waves have picked up
I think it's time to call it
well thanks for watching guys hope you
enjoyed this video if you want to see
more videos like this make sure to click
subscribe and check out our video
playlist where we have all of our videos
by topic thanks for watching guys we'll
see you next time if you like this video
don't forget to check out the outdoor
Boys YouTube channel where we have
hundreds of videos just like this and
don't forget to click subscribe so you
can see other great videos every
Saturday morning hit that Bell button
you'll get notifications thanks for
watching
[Music]